COLT MCANLIS: Everybody.
My name is Colt McAnlis.
I'm a game developer advocate
here at Google, focusing on
Native Client and Chrome.
Thank you all for coming
to the Google Dev Day.
We've got a lot of great talks
so far today and hopefully
this will continue in our
processes to get you ready to
use web gaming, I suppose
is the big thing.
Here at GDC, there's a lot of
focus on console, but everyone
is moving towards web gaming.
And we understand that this is
an important trend in sort of
the evolution of gaming
as a whole.
And what we're going to talk
about today is best practices
in developing those
web gaming.
So being at Google, you sort of
have an interesting ability
to look at the broad spectrum
of data and the number of
developers out there on the web
doing some amazing things,
and mine that data, look at it
from different angles, and
sort of construct the best
practices document.
And that's really what
this talk is about.
This doc very specifically is
focused to developers who are
not already multi-millionaires
at developing web games.
If you're already if you're a
making millions and millions
of dollars with your web game,
chances are you know
everything that I'm about
to talk about.
So feel free, check
your emails.
Zone out.
Figure out what parties you're
going to at GDC.
Have fun with that.
In mean time for everybody
else, we're going to talk
today about developing a web
game in modern browsers.
Now the interesting point
here is twofold.
First off is I'm saying
in modern browsers.
So I think we can all agree that
when we talk about web
gaming, there's sort of this
threshold of minimum feature
set that we're not willing
to go below.
A lot of developers when you
talk about web gaming and they
say well, what about ubiquity?
What about reach?
But at the same time, they're
not really able to make the
experience of their game
translate to these older
browsers that don't have
the same capabilities.
So today, I want to make sure
that we're focusing things
since you are at the Google
Developer Day, that we're
actually talking about Chrome.
Chrome is considered
a modern browser.
It's a very important
linchpin in the
pushing of things forward.
Google has a lot of vested
interest in making sure that
this is a platform that we can
continue to push the internet
forward in positive ways, and
basically enrich the ecosystem
for all of humanity.
Because pretty much everyone
uses the internet nowadays.
And if you don't use the
internet, hopefully
we'll fix that soon.
Anyhow, let's get started.
So let's start from the top.
If you're a console developer
and you've never shipped a web
game, you have no idea
we're talking about.
And you generally have no idea
what entails web games.
So let's talk about
that for a minute.
So first off, a web game
generally have
some sort of client.
The client is downloaded from a
server to the client to the
end user's machine in a web
page that does some
interesting things.
On the end user's machine, it
usually does some sort of
scripting and displays.
This means code execution as
well as visual display--
2D, 3D, or whatnot.
In addition to that,
this is served--
the client, including the
scripting data and all the
information is to display--
is served from some sort
of content server.
This could be a web server or a
scalable distributed network.
And it also has some relational
context to a database.
This is because most people
nowadays in web gaming, they
require you to log in.
They store your saved game state
in the cloud somewhere--
have you purchase an item, who's
your friends, have you
invited this person,
what level are you.
This information is
all stored in some
sort of large database.
And I could rattle off a bunch
of acronyms about what
databases are and what databases
aren't, but we'll
stick to just saying
that clients
communicate with databases.
Once you've got your content
server to distribute your
content to your client side and
your database to sort of
understand the relation to the
user and the universe that
you're trying to generate, some
games also have a game
play server.
Now a game play server is really
the realm of what we
call AAA niche gaming.
So this is things like first
person shooters, real time
strategy games, things that
run at 60 Hertz on some
ungodly monitor that you need
some computer from the future
to generally be able to run
on your local machine.
These games effectively require
some piece of hardware
running in some server farm
actually running the
simulation of the game to keep
all of the clients in sync at
the proper frequencies.
Now some games require
this on the web.
Some don't.
But it's important to
point this out here.
So once you've got this working,
sooner or later
you're going to want
a social graph.
This is the real power
of the web.
When you start talking about
what's the difference between
a web game and a console game
and a PC game that you go buy
from a retailer, what you're
really looking at is that a
web game gives you direct access
to a social graph in an
immersive manner that
you can't get
in those other relations.
And then once you have all of
this, the final thing a web
game does is monetize.
At the end of the day, you
guys gotta make money.
We've all got significant others
and mother-in-laws who
say we should get real jobs
instead of making video games
for a living.
We want to prove them wrong by
monetizing effectively and
making it rain with
dollar bills.
That's sort of the goal.
The good news here is that as
Google as a platform provider,
we've actually got software
services in place to handle
and address all of these needs
for a web game on your behalf.
And the rest of the talk, we're
going to be talking
about the best practices
in doing all of these
items you see here.
But we're going to do it from
the context of the Google
services, mainly because of
well, obviously we want you to
use our services.
We think that they're
fantastic.
But also, it just sort of gives
us a line in the sand as
far as documentation
is concerned.
We want to make sure that we can
provide the documentation
for the ideas that we're
talking about.
So then our content databases,
what we're going to talk about
today is Google App Engine.
It provides you both content
distribution for web pages and
static data, dynamic data,
everything you need, as well
as a relational database.
You actually store your
table information,
players and what not.
For social graph, we've
got Google+.
If you don't have a Google+
account, go get one now.
Make sure you sign up by the
end of the talk so then you
can follow me on Google+ where
I spend most of my time
posting about web gaming and
Native Client development.
And for monetization, we've
got this great integration
point called Google Wallet which
is super easy to use.
It has a lot of benefits that
we'll talk to you towards the
end of the slide.
In addition to these right here,
we've also got a couple
others that you should be
interested in the we'll talk
about today.
The first is Google Analytics.
Google Analytics is typically
designed as a way to track
your users' movements and who
visits your website, where
they come from, how they're
using your website, what's
wrong, what's broken, what's
popular, and whatnot.
But this could actually be
modified with a few APIs to
work very well for games.
We'll talk about how
you use that.
And then finally is the
Chrome Web Store.
Chrome Web Store is an amazing
sort of outlet that Google has
launched about a year and a
half ago now that provides
sort of a content discovery
portal for all things web.
We've got an amazing plethora
of applications both
games and not games.
But if you're looking for an
amazing place for users to
develop your content in a
curated, informative way,
definitely check out the
Chrome Web Store.
Now on this graph here you'll
notice that we don't really
have a solution for
gameplay servers.
And the only thing I can say
about that is stay tuned.
So the rundown.
So grab your coffee, grab your
laptop, grab your phone.
Let's talk about what we're
going to do today.
So we're going to talk about
content distribution,
databases, proper
practices there.
We're going to talk about login
and authentication.
You'd actually be surprised
about how many problems there
are with login and
authentication that make users
drop off the radar.
Then we're going to talk about
localization, rendering, web
and platform, and
user metrics.
These are all important
things.
And then finally, we're going
to finish this off with
monetization which--
I put that at the end because
we all know you're only here
to talk about monetization.
The rest of this stuff
is icing on the cake.
So let's talk about
serving content.
Start at the beginning.
So let's say all of your
data is served
from some server somewhere.
Your data is usually uploaded
to the web.
That web creates the
information.
It stores it.
It scales it.
It replicates it.
You can see here are some
of standard items do you
typically see on your server--
HTML, JavaScript, images,
JSON files, ZIPs,
sound files, and whatnot.
What happens is that
the client--
the user machine effectively--
sits around and it will
generally do a page load or
resource or load or from
JavaScript an XHttpRequest you
can Google that and figure
out what the
proper syntax is there--
to fetch this data from
the internet or
the server in general.
The cool thing is
that Chrome--
again, we're going to
focus on that--
Chrome will automatically cache
anything given through
this load for you.
So if you actually do a page
load, Chrome will go ahead and
grab the HTML and JavaScript
and JPGs and
JSON data for you.
If you need to grab your ZIP
files or your OGG datas,
you're probably going through
some resource load or some
XHttpRequest. And when you do
those, Chrome will cache that
data as well.
The good news about this is
that caching is automatic.
You don't have to do anything
to take advantage of It.
You grab your data.
It's stored on the local disk.
When the user requests that data
again, Chrome will check
the local disk first. If it's
there, it'll grab it and load
it up and use it.
It it's timed out or if it
detects that there's some of
the reason it needs, it'll go
back to the web and grab it
from there.
This is all handled
on your behalf.
The bad news about this though
is that it is in fact handled
on your behalf, which means that
any time during the day
the user can either delete their
cache or go download 17
gigs of other data.
And that data will invalidate
the cache and
push your stuff out.
So really, you have no ability
to track when your data's
going to be evicted, and how
that's going to relate to the
end user experience.
So the good news is modern
browsers actually implement a
specific file store API.
The file store API allows you
to write to a persistent
obfuscated sandbox section
of the user's hard drive.
Which means that when you
actually grab this data from
the web, you can actually store
it somewhere so that you
control the caching, so that
then you directly control the
user's experience with
the caching.
And that's very important.
If you've got 14 gigabytes of
data sitting around, you're
going to want to know how the
user is loading it and when
they're loading so that you
can optimize for their
experience.
At the end of the day, they're
the guys give you the money.
You gotta make it
right for them.
So let's talk about scaling.
So let's say you've made in the
most amazing game ever.
It's called catfightpig.com.
Whatever.
I don't know.
And you make this game.
You put it up on the web.
And then all of a sudden, you
get a million billion 100,000
people that decide to download
your game and play and run it.
Well, the problem is that
you've just went viral.
And if you don't have a proper
scaling solution on your
server side to handle the
scaling the just happened on
the client side, your viral
ability is going to go through
the floor really quick.
So what happens is you need to
move to something like a
distributable content
distribution server.
So you need to find some way,
use some service out there to
actually replicate your content
across all of these
different servers so that it can
be handed to the clients
as they request it.
Now there's some great services
out there, for
example Google App Engine which
will handle replication
as well as regional replication
on your behalf.
That means that say someone in
France is accessing your data,
and you've uploaded it to
servers here in California.
They're still going to get fast
access speeds to that
data because Google's handled
all the back end of making
sure that it exists on a web
server that's near that user
so they get it at the
correct speeds.
The good thing is you don't
have to worry about that.
If you've just rented some web
server sitting somewhere in
someone's basement, you're not
going to get the same ability.
So international customers or
customers that may not have
direct access to that guy's
basement, Bill's basement
we'll call it, are going to
get a lower feature set.
So when you're serving this
data, it's important to think
about what the costs associated
with it are.
Hosting data has a cost. And
let's talk about how it's
being used.
So today, typically developers
use loose files.
They define--
and this is sort of defined as
a result of the way that HTML
and JavaScript works.
You can simply go in there.
You define an image.
You define a JavaScript link.
You define these as an exact
path to a resource on the web.
So what happens is the browser
will effectively issue
asynchronous loads for all
of these web resources.
So it'll go out to
the internet.
It'll say hey, please
give me this thing.
Let me know once you've
received it.
Now this is fantastic.
This mean that the web browser
and the client are sort of
optimizing the load process
based on your behalf, sending
all this stuff out
and getting them.
And of course, when it does
receive it, it puts it in the
Chrome cache, which is
again good for you.
Of course, we talked about the
Chrome cache before and all
the benefits and downsides
of that.
Now anyone who's shipped a game
on the PC or on console
knows that archiving is a
much, much better way to
handle this.
Because of the fact that any
time you read from a resource
or a medium--
be it hard drive or CD or
even the internet--
you're going to induce a lot
of bandwidth incurrence.
So you're going to say
give me this load.
It's going to take 10 seconds,
20 seconds, a minute, two
minutes, whatever.
You want to reduce that
amount of time.
Now if you have tons and tons
and tons and tons of files,
you may have to be blocking some
files, loading others in
different orders.
It just gets into madness.
So what most developers do is
they'll actually zip all of
this data up, or they'll archive
the information.
They put all of their loose
files into a single archive,
and then they download
that archive.
Now once you do this though,
you have to note that the
archiving of this information
is not going to come through
the same paths.
What you want to be doing to
make sure that this archive
comes down properly
is store it in the
persistent file store.
And then you're going to want to
modify your runtime code so
that it checks the persistent
file store for the existence
of the zip first before actually
communicating with
the rest of their system.
So this is a benefit.
This means that you are now
controlling how the assets are
bundled, how they're
distributed, how they get to
the user's machine, and how the
user machine responds to
having them.
This gives you a
lot of control.
Again, this is important because
it optimizes for the
user's experience.
You can stream data in, you can
stream it out, et cetera.
Now one of the bad sides of
archiving is twofold.
First off is that you sort of
lose the ability to just
randomly grab files
from the internet.
You have to grab these
larger blobs.
And these larger blobs then
sometimes take more time, so
you have to make different
loading screens and
asynchronous results and
all these other things.
So you want to move towards
something called segmenting.
Effectively, the idea behind
this is it you're not going to
just create one large zip file
for all of your assets.
You're going to create many
smaller archives.
And these archives are going
to be bundle based upon
different parameters
and metrics.
For instance, you could say that
your original zip file is
only five megs.
That zip file contains
everything like the main menu
and the starting guide so the
user can load your game and
see a spinning character and do
their character creation.
Meanwhile, it's actually
streaming in the other
archive behind it.
So this allows your user to get
into the game immediately,
and then spend time doing
something instead of waiting
for the loading bar to get
all their data in there.
Another reason to segment your
assets is due to monetization.
So let's say that your
particular game where you sell
chunks of game content in
one gigabyte bursts.
So chapter five, chapter
six, chapter seven.
And there's a large demand for
each one of those from a
monetization standpoint.
What you're going to want to do
is you're going to want to
segment each of those in two
separate monetization
categories so that you don't
stream that data to the user
until they've actually
paid you for it.
Again, hosting and streaming
cost something.
So you want to optimize the
content that you're streaming
to the user based upon whether
or not they've paid you.
You don't want to have a 15
gigabyte game, stream it all
of the user, and only
have 2% of those
users actually convert.
That means you're going to be
wasting a lot of money.
It doesn't make sense.
With this though, you're going
to need some sort of manifest
file because the final cool
thing about archiving and some
sort of segmented set up is
you actually need a way to
define what zips are invalid
and not invalid from the
persistent file store.
So the user will go grab a zip
from the net, they'll store it
to the local persistent store,
and then you go upload a new
zip because you've made balance
changes or whatnot.
Now the user needs the ability
to query some sort of file
that says whether or not that
zip is out of date.
So that way, they say hey,
this is out of date.
We need to go fetch it from
the server and update our
local cache view.
So basically you want to segment
all of your stuff
based upon game resources,
monetization resources, and
then create some sort of
manifest file that allows the
client machine to keep
up with that data.
Now let's talk about Google
App Engine specifically.
Let's just focus on that for a
minute and say that that's
where you're hosting
your concept.
So you can store your segmented
binary archives here.
That's fantastic.
This allows you to carefully
control your server costs.
Again, this is a metric that
matters to you because how
you're serving your data
directly relates to how much
it costs you to serve
that data.
Google App Engine allows you
to store any asset that's
under 32 megabytes HTML style
or sort of direct store.
Which means you just upload it
and it's no big deal and it's
stored just like
any other file.
It's sort of seamless
integration for you.
You can read the documentation
on how exactly that works.
For anything above 32 megabytes
though, you have to
store it from a different
file store and that's
the blobstore API.
Now it's still hosted on Google
App Engine, but you
have to use a separate
API to access it.
And this is again really
important.
This sort of forces you to
optimize how you're getting
your data, because there may
be tiered costs available.
There may be specifics streaming
solutions you need
to be aware of.
This is important stuff.
Also for that, you need
to set the browser
cache expiration date.
So any of this binary data
that's served from Google App
Engine, when it hits the
client, the client's
effectively going to
say here's how long
this data is valid.
Here's how long I think you
should keep this around.
So the cache then has this large
amazing metric that says
hey, all of these items in the
cache, they've expired, they
can be expelled to bring
new data in.
You can actually set the browser
time for that file.
And if you click that link
there, you can actually set it
to be some larger time.
I think the default is
actually 10 minutes.
So that means for a user playing
your game, let's say
there's 56 hours of game play.
If you don't set this particular
header for the data
that's served to your client,
that means that the client,
the browser, Chrome, the cache,
will say that after 10
minutes, all that data can be
invalidated and flushed to
something else.
Now if you're using the
persistent file store, this
shouldn't necessarily
be a big deal.
But in some cases it's
still smart to set
that expiration date.
This brings us to a public
service announcement.
Do not use the existence of data
on the user's machine to
represent that the user has
purchased that data.
So anyone in here who has
handled any sort of problems
with piracy for video games
knows this to be true.
Effectively, if a user purchases
your item and then
refunds that purchase and the
item's data has been streamed
to them and stored on disk and
the user who loads your game
up, what happens?
If your code actually goes
through and says, oh the sword
of Antioch exists
on your desk.
You must have access to it.
Then the user could effectively
buy all the items,
get them all downloaded, return
all the items. You
don't get any money, but they
get all the free stuff.
That's not good.
You want to make sure that
you don't do it that way.
So public service
announcement.
Do not use the existence of
the data on the disc that
you've streamed to the user to
represent the fact that the
user has bought the item.
Just don't do it.
It's madness.
Let's talk about databases.
This is again correlated
databases, so
not like binary databases.
So App Engine has relational
databases using
the GQL query language.
And if you click on the GQL
link, it'll take you to a nice
amazing page that talks about
the syntax, how to use it, how
not to use it.
It also gives you great in-depth
examples about how to
get started using it and all
these amazing things.
As far as app Engine is
concerned, it really gives you
the trifecta of hosting data,
hosting content, and also
giving you database.
The cool thing too is it
auto-scales to handle demand.
This is the most important
thing.
Let's say that you go a year and
a half of having your app
online and nobody
downloads it.
Then one day, you add in a cat
with a really cool pink wizard
hat, then all of a sudden
the entire internet has
to have your game.
When the entire internet starts
knocking on your door,
the servers for Google App
Engine will scale up
dynamically to handle
that balance load.
You don't have to do anything.
If you've rented your
own servers, this
is a massive problem.
All of a sudden you need to
employ five IT guys and six
more server racks and buy all
this hardware that then in
another month you
may not need.
So you've invested a lot of
sunk cost into something
that's pretty much seasonal.
The fact that App
Engine handles
that for you is amazing.
Of course, the cost is based
upon performance here.
So this means that as more users
are using your service
and monetizing through you
service, of course the cost
goes up a little bit.
The goal is to make sure that
the ratio between these two is
always set in your favor.
And to do this, to make sure
of this the first thing you
need to do is make
sure the set the
cache-time for any GET responses.
And now a GET response on the
internet for those of you
haven't used it, you
get effectively a
POST and GET reset--
a POST and GET message is
defined as either querying
data from some database or
server or page versus setting
data to that server or
database or page.
Now again, a GET effectively
is a pull request.
So what's occurring here
is that you're pulling
information from Google
App Engine.
And what's happening is when you
requests that data, Google
App Engine will go find
that data, say OK,
this result has occurred.
I'm going to cache this away
in case this user or a next
user or someone else goes and
tries to fetch the same data.
If it finds it in its cache
automatically, it'll go ahead
and return that data for you.
But you need to set the
cache-time for that.
Otherwise much like the Chrome
cache in the client's machine,
it'll evict it based
upon duration.
So here's how to do
that in Python.
Again, there's great links on
the intertubes about how to do
this directly.
So we create a date object.
We set it to a specific age
way, way in the future.
And then in our response packet
that Google App Engine
provides to the client, we
actually set the maximum age
for that data to some
large metric.
So this allows the clients
to then cache it on
their side, as well.
Which is good because then the
client says hey, I'm going to
query the same data.
I don't even have to
go to the internet.
I just grab it locally.
This brings us to the next point
is using Memcache which
is on the server side of that.
Click the link, get
more information.
Memcache is effectively intended
for fast access to
cache results of queries.
Now again, you've got 100
million users all hitting your
Google App Engine instance at
one time, all querying data,
all grabbing it from different
directions.
It would be great if you were
able to analyze that and
figure out what the most common
things are and then
optimize different
sets for that.
Now if you don't have that
ability your or the stuff is
just too far across the map,
then you want to use something
called Memcache.
And Memcache works like this.
Effectively you test whether or
not the Memcache has some
specific data.
If it has the data, then
you return that data.
So let's say the user says I
want to find out how many
people are playing the game
right now in Argentina.
And you store that
in into Memcache.
It's already there, so you
return the number of people
playing the game in Argentina.
If it doesn't exist--
if the data hasn't
been stored in Memcache--
then you actually get the data,
find out how many people
are playing, store it into
Memcache, and then return it
to the user.
So this means the next person
that comes through the says
hey, I'm in Argentina, find the
number of people playing,
it'll return the
proper result.
And of course, there's a lot of
amazing things behind the
scenes about what happens when
that data changes without them
knowing about it, things
like that.
We aren't going to
get into that.
Click the link, learn more.
Expand your horizons.
Learn some new stuff today.
So most of your clients will
again as we talked about have
some sort of networked
component.
You're going to want to
communicate with other players
is the basic multiplayer
thing.
You're on the internet.
You want to play with
other people.
Social is more fun.
So there's one technique
to do.
This is called polling, which
is effectively where each
client that's connected to a
service will actually poll the
server and say hey, has
anything changed.
If something's changed, the
server pushes the data to the
client through the request
process, and
everyone moves forward.
The problem with this is that
for low latency games, games
where things only update once
every 5 minutes, 10 minutes,
30 seconds, something like that,
you're going to spend a
lot of time asking the server
for things effectively
clogging your pipe,
upping your cost,
et cetera, et cetera.
And this can be avoided by using
something on Google App
Engine called the Channel API.
The Channel API effectively
allows your client to
communicate the server and open
a pipe that stays open.
So then the server when data
does change, like the number
of players in Argentina, that
when that does change, the
server tells the client hey,
this data has changed.
I need you to update
on your side.
This allows your client your
server to communicate only
when they have to.
And this is a good,
good thing.
Because this means that your
overhead for communication is
low, the amount of cost
spent on transfer and
bandwidth is low.
This Is a fantastic thing.
One of the downsides with the
Channel API right now is that
it can only communicate
with JavaScript.
So this is really highlighted
and designed for
web games in general.
For those of you who want to
communicate with the Channel
API on Google App Engine and
using C++ or some other sort
of language, it's worth noting
that the Channel API is
actually based upon a protocol
called XMPP.
And effectively it wraps all
the communication and
handshaking up into JavaScript
and provides a JavaScript
library to you.
Now if you are so inclined that
you would like to use
this technology, feel free to
actually deconstruct what the
JavaScript is wrapping and
figure out the proper
handshakes and message
passing.
That's up to you.
I have talked with some people
and don't see any particular
wrappers for different languages
in the pipe.
But if there's a lot of
user demand, maybe
we can change that.
So email me.
I'm here to help.
Login and authentication.
This is a pain point.
So how many of you in here got
wanted to play a game and then
as soon as it asks you to log
in or create an account, you
just shut the game off.
That's barrier zero.
Like man, I just want
to play this game.
Why do you need my data?
I don't want to give
you my information.
I'm afraid what you're going to
do with it or I don't want
to get spammed.
So let's talk about best
practices for login and
authentication.
So everyone's seen this.
This is a standard login.
Please login.
If you don't have an account,
click here to create one.
The problem is, your website
may have that, but so every
other site on the internet.
Everyone says I want to
create your login.
I want to create an account.
I want to hold user information,
et cetera.
This is not beneficial
for the user.
The user does not want
to come to your page
to create an account.
That's not the reason
they're there.
The reason they're there
is to play your game.
And you want to reduce the
barrier to that, because that
means you'll get more money.
So the goal here is rather than
asking the user to create
an account, allow them to use an
existing account to login.
And there's some great
technologies out there that
allow this.
One of them is OpenID.
I'm going to talk about OpenID
here for a second.
OpenID effectively
allows you--
it's effectively
a decentralized
authentication service.
So the user can effectively use
multiple different logins
to access your account.
And effectively what occurs here
is the user will click
their given account provider
that they want--
Google, Yahoo, Blogger,
something like that.
They'll click sign in.
Sign in auto-direct the user
to another page handled by
those providers.
Authentication will occur
on their side.
You will then get a proper
result saying did they pass or
did they fail.
So you don't even have to handle
all the handshaking.
All you have to do is provide
the link, the information, let
them let them handle it.
This is fantastic.
This means you get ti take all
of those different dialogues
and bring them down.
So the user can use something
they already have to login.
Reduction of barriers.
It's what we're all about.
Now how this works with your
side though is that when the
user logs in with one of these
other services or through
OpenID, it's going to hand you
an authentication key.
It's going to say here's
the GUID for this user.
Now it's important that you do
not pass this user ID around
sort of willynilly.
This is a very important
concept here.
So you're going to have your
relational data table here,
and you're going to receive
that auth key.
The problem is you're also going
to receive the auth key
probably for a number of other
providers as well.
So let's say you really want
to go the gamut here.
You're allow the user to use
login their Google+ ID, with
their Facebook ID, with their
Apple ID, and all these other
sorts of things.
You're going to have unique
IDs populating this table.
So the question is there, if
you're going to hand those
keys around, which one
do you pass around?
Is the first one they uses?
Is it the last one they use?
It is some MD5 hash of all
the things concatenated.
No.
The better way to do
this is to actually
create a user game key.
So the first time the user logs
into your service, if
their unique ID in some way,
shape, or form doesn't exist
already in the database, go
ahead and create one and
create a new user key.
You want to use that
user key everywhere
else in your database.
So if you've got your primary
player information, the number
of games they have, their
friends list, this should all
be sorted by the game key that's
unique to your game,
not the key that's unique to
their authentication provider.
It's very important for you.
In addition to this, this
is actually sort of an
interesting concept that people
go back and forth on.
On one side you, want to reduce
the barrier to the user
logging into your service
because you want to make sure
to make sure that they get
there, they get to play in the
game, and they get the service
benefits from logging in that
you provide for them.
On the other side though, you
want to create a massive
amount of security.
I think one of the constant news
articles you have always
showing up on the internet
is my account
got hacked by blank.
People are constantly losing
their accounts.
They're constantly
losing their game
progress, their servers.
And within in-app purchase being
sort of where it is and
the dominating force it has in
the monetization realm right
now, you want to make sure that
users have a secure way
of logging into your game and
keeping their content secure,
so that their sister or their
brother or their angry ex
doesn't go and do something
malicious.
So one way to do this is
two-step security How this
works is that the user logs in
with their first ID, so their
username and the password.
And they're then prompted to
enter a verification code
generated by some application.
Now this application could come
in many forms. It could
be a key ring that has
information associated to it.
It can come from your mobile
phone, et cetera, et cetera.
But the purpose is that the user
has to then authenticate
with a random number that's
generated on some time series.
So for you or random person to
access someone else's account
that has two-step authentication
set up, you not
only have to have their
username, but you have to have
their password as well, and you
have to have their mobile
phone and be able to get access
in their mobile phone
to that program that actually
provides this key.
Now this is pretty good security
across the board.
The good news is for you that
you can set up this service on
your web server and on your
account for free and use it
for free, and provide it
to your users for free.
Really there's no reason
to not allow this.
Now don't force it.
Allow your users to decide
if they want it or not.
But there's no reason
to not do it.
In fact there's a great link
here at the bottom.
If you click that, it'll take to
page that has a JavaScript
implementation, a server side
implementation, and actually
shows you how to put the whole
thing together within like 20
minutes of work.
Now that's fantastic.
And the cool thing is they can
use their existing Google
authenticator application on
their iPhone or their Android
phone, so they could
use your service.
It's a great thing to do.
Localization.
This is a big one.
Console developers.
Let's see your hands if you've
ever ran into problems with
localization.
Everyone.
Exactly.
It's not a big deal.
Localizing matters.
And this should matter more as
a web game than any sort of
console developer or any
PC developer has
ever told you before.
There are big markets
internationally.
We've seen some games monetize
horribly in the States that
completely blew up in Europe.
Like David Hasselhoff.
No one bought this guy's musical
album in America.
But for some reason,
he's a pop diva in
Europe and in Germany.
I don't get.
I didn't like his music.
I listened to it.
It wasn't for me, but
hey, I'm this guy.
So the fact is that if you're
going actually take your game
and move it into these markets
to try to capitalize on the
monetization opportunities
there, the first step you need
to look at is language.
Your game has a certain amount
of strings or certain amount
of text that's being prompted
to the user.
You've got menus.
You got dialogues.
You've got item descriptions.
You've got cost description.
You have quest understandings.
You've got a lot of text.
If you want to move into these
other markets, you need to
communicate in their language
because not everyone speaks
the language that you speak.
The problem is that all the
languages don't act the same.
For instance, the first problem
is the languages all
read in different directions.
So let's say you've created
this amazing storyline and
your UI designer came through
created amazing UI for this
for the storyline to present it
to the user and display it.
The problem is when you put it
in Japanese, Japanese reads
vertically instead
of horizontally.
So what happens now?
How does the UI stand
up to that?
This sort of forces you to go
back and change your UI layout
based upon the languages
that are available.
In addition that, long words
and phrases are a problem.
How the language is translated
in your language, English for
example, to other languages,
German, may
be completely different.
Like what's 3 words or 15
characters in English maybe 37
characters in German.
A great story about this
is in-app purchase.
So the in-app purchase guys had
originally created some
specific UI and specific
dialogue, and had a specific
window size and had it all
scaling and working perfectly.
But when that data was
auto-translated to German,
what happened was the text
actually pushed the buy button
off the side of the
screen and you
couldn't resize the window.
So what happened was if you were
trying to buy this item
in Germany, you couldn't buy it
because the buy button was
completely gone.
This is the type of problems
that you need to be thinking
about with your UI.
Of course, word wrap and
everything was implemented
very quickly.
And then everyone was able to
purchase, but the problem is
that this is real.
So how you do then.
So let's say OK, cool.
I want to localize my product.
The first step is detecting
the user's language.
In JavaScript, you can use a
nifty little function here
navigator.language.
Simple and easy to use.
The problem is that this
actually isn't
changeable by the user.
So if the user actually goes
into their browser and checks
the language in their browser,
it doesn't change the result
of navigator.language.
This is actually a common
problem that
everyone deals with.
What it does change, though,
is it changes is the
HTTPaccept header when you're
doing a GET or SET response.
So there's kind of a work around
in hack, but I'm giving
a fast pass here so you
don't have to deal
with the same problem.
So what you can do it this is
knowing that the GET and SET
requests actually have the real
language that the user
has set in their browser, you
could actually poll a server
and get the result back
and that'll have the
real language in it.
And here's how to do that.
There's a great website
up there called
ajaxhttpheaders.appspot.com.
He's a very generous guy.
You can click the link at the
bottom to go his post about
how he did all this stuff.
But effectively, you
send off an AJAX
request to that location.
When you get your response,
you query for a specific
Accept-Language.
And that's going to have the two
digit code that actually
responds to the user's
language.
Once you get that two digit
code, you can then pass that
off your localization process
and that will then define
which table you pull
strings from.
The link at the bottom by the
way has the source code for
the client side JavaScript
function which you're looking
at here, as well as the server
side code which is posted at
ajaxhttpheaders.
And I think he actually has
a jQuery module as well.
So if you're trying to
detect the language,
navigator.language works well,
but this is actually sort of
the definitive thing.
Now the cool thing is-- and I
feel this isn't really a best
practice, but this is important
to point this out as
a tool chain process--
is that there are some
tools to actually do
translation for you.
Most the time for game
development, you usually get
all your strings in a file,
outsource that to some firm in
Dublin usually is the case, and
they'll charge you some
money and they'll give you back
everything translated.
This doesn't always work.
Like sometimes you need to
iterate on things, you don't
have time to translating
or you don't
have a budget to translate.
There's some really cool tools
that Google provides that
allows you to fix that.
The first is Google Translate.
So you can type in some stuff
on one side, convert it the
other language on the other.
This is easy.
Copy, paste, you're
good to go.
This doesn't work in situations
though where
there's sort of live chat.
So let's say you've got a
chat window up and I'm
communicating to someone
who's speaking Spanish.
I need the ability to
take my string and
convert it to their language.
Google Translate provides an API
where you can put in your
language, put in what language
you want it to go to, and
it'll return a packet with the
proper translated strength.
In addition to that, it also
provide a detect function.
So let's say the user is using
a language and they haven't
specified it properly
or whatnot.
Let the string get passed into
Google Translate API, and
Google Translate will sort of
parse through its massive
database of languages and words
and return to you what
the language is.
Now again this is fantastic
because you can use it sort of
at a tool level.
You could actually say write a
little application that will
take all of your table strings
written in your source
language like English, and for
each string send off a query
to Google Translate
and it'll give you
the translated string.
This works, although
it takes some time.
So the better solution is
actually to use an amazing
product called Translator
Toolkit.
And Translator Toolkit is free
for anyone to go and use.
Translator Toolkit allows
you to upload a file--
XML, HTML, CSV, things like
that-- and it'll actually
translate the whole thing for
you just in one shot go.
So this is actually the tool
you want to be using.
If you've got all of your
strings segmented into
different sections, you can take
each one of those files,
upload it to Google Translator,
the Toolkit, hit
the button, and it'll
push it out.
Now the cool thing is here is it
actually allows you to step
through each one of the items
that it's translated.
So you can actually see Hello,
world see example blahblahblah
actually gets translated
into this over here.
I hope the Native Client team
does not mind me using their
page for example purposes.
So definitely use these tools
if you're doing translation.
Let's talk about display
and rendering.
So we've got a game.
We've talked about the
server side aspects.
Let's talk about the
client side.
The client side.
You're going to display
your game.
Let's talk about what
that means.
First off is this
is a modern web.
We have to face it.
If we really want people to
take gaming on the web
seriously and take all of the
skill sets that we've
acclimated over the past 30
years of gaming on PC and
gaming on consoles, we have to
talk about the GPU being used
in a web page and in
a web browser.
And the good news is,
we've got this.
We've got technologies like
OpenGL in Native Client.
WebGL, and we also have
technologies like
Hardware-Accelerated Canvas.
We'll talk about that
in a minute.
The important thing here those
is I'm sure you've all heard
the news that with these
technologies, you need to be
aware that some of the driver
implementations may not be
secure, may not be safe.
This means that potential
malicious users can write some
sort of code, a GPU-specific
code, that when a user loads
it on the local machine does
something nasty and gnarly.
For the most part, the teams
work in the modern browsers to
fix these, update these, and
make that sure these patches
are proper.
For the stuff they just can't
fix, there's actually a
presented blacklisted drivers.
They say that if you try to load
this content and you have
this driver on your
machine, nah.
Not going to happen.
Why?
Because the security risk is
more important than the
content viewing.
Now this is really important.
Think of you.
You are a developer and you put
content on the web, and
you put a game on the web and
the user goes to that site and
potentially is available for
some sort of hack or
something going on.
That's not good, because they're
going to come back and
say that it's your problem, not
the web browser's problem
or the malicious person's
problem or
someone else's problem.
So you like this.
You want to make sure that you
can detect if they have a
blacklisted driver, respond
to it early.
Here's I do that.
It's she really simple.
You take this little
snippet of code.
Effectively all you're doing in
JavaScript is you get the
canvas element and you try to
create a WebGL context.
If the WebGL context fails,
chances are the user either
has inadequate resources to
run the game, which you
wouldn't want them to be able to
run it anyway, or they have
a blacklisted driver.
In either case, running this
little script right here
before you start caching
or loading or doing any
processing is of vital
importance because you can
then tell the user hey,
something's wrong.
Go update, go do something.
Does need to.
In addition here-- you can
actually see something else--
is that if this passes, you can
actually do other tests
here like does your hardware
support this max texture size?
Which is also really
important.
You have to scale to make sure
that the hardware which is not
homogeneous can play well
with your game.
Now most internet users aren't
going to like this because
this means that I have to create
different versions of
my product for different
tiers of performance.
But in reality, PC developers
have had
this problem for years.
This is nothing new to us.
We've been dealing with
this a long time.
And the same problems and
the same solutions
have existed there.
This is a well-documented thing
about how to deal with.
So I suggest if this is an
issue that you're worried
about, definitely read up
on the documentation.
Now the next thing you
need to be concerned
with is sandbox rendering.
Now you have to understand that
again with these drivers
and the security issues
involved that we don't
actually allow the script code
that's being executed to go
right to the driver
and right to the
graphics processing unit.
This could expose a whole slew
of problems. So instead what
occurs is we actually put all
of the processing and direct
correlation with the APIs in
a separate process that's
running somewhere else.
So you got your main Chrome
process and you've got a
rendering process.
All of the data is then pushed
into an RPC buffer.
That RPC buffer will get the
commands and then some time in
the future, push them to
the render process.
And what this means you're sort
of creating a frame of
buffering and a frame of latency
in getting all this
through the pipe.
To dig into this a little bit
deeper, you have to be wary
and the reason this is the
problem is you're got to get
something called
a render stall.
Basically what happens is you're
going to do some work.
You're going to draw some
objects, you're going to
update some vertex buffers, and
you're going to fill in
your entire RPC buffer.
So that when you go to try and
do something that pushes in
that RPC buffer, it's
going to block.
It's going to say I've
got no more room.
What's going to happen there is
even though you're not done
with your frame and you have
all this other stuff to do,
it's going to insert a
sync FLUSH command,
effectively a glFinish.
What a sync FLUSH command's
going to do is it's going to
wait for that entire buffer
to be consumed
by the render process.
And it's going to block your
calling application until that
work is done.
So what's going to happen
is you will be
chugging along fine.
You'll see that the timing
observation for draw objects
and update VBs is pretty
much consistent.
And then all of a sudden,
you're going to hit 30
milliseconds draw
object frame.
And this is not ideal, because
you're going to
try to drill down.
You're going to be like why is
this one draw object taking so
long, and if I move it around
it's not in the same spot and
oh, my God.
What's happening?
What's happening is it has
nothing to do with the way
you're calling the API.
It has everything to do with
what API's doing on the back
end that you have very
little control over.
But you do have some control.
And This is really important.
Swap buffers at the end of a
frame for rendering in WebGL
or OpenGL ES 2.0 in Native
Client will actually kick off
a glFinish call on
your behalf.
And what this does is it
actually force the RPC buffer
to get flushed for you.
Now the intent here is can we
insert flushes ahead of time
to make sure that we never hit
one of these sync flushes.
So to do this, effectively what
you have to do is you
have to figure out the optimal
places to insert a glFlush
command in your rendering
process.
This will allow you to do some
drawing, flush the buffer, do
some more drawing, and flush
the buffer again.
This will keep you from ever
hitting the sync flush if you
do it right.
You may hit it every now again
in periods of high bandwidth
or high amount of processing
churn.
But the goal is to analyze your
system, figure out where
the heavy points are, in insert
these manual flushes in
strategic positions to reduce
and keep that pipeline moving
as efficient as possible.
Think of it like a factory.
Like you're trying to build
cars, you're trying to keep
everything going through smooth
so that there's no
pipeline bottlenecks.
So canvas rendering.
I talked about this.
The latest versions of Chrome
actually have GPU accelerated
campus rendering.
I believe this is unveiled
as default in Chrome 17.
It might be Chrome 16.
Fact check me on that.
But what this means is that
you as a developer can
actually just use the same
canvas commands--
draw, tesselate, do all
these other things--
and behind the scenes Chrome
will actually go through and
use the GPU on your behalf.
This is amazing because this
means that all of the concept
and all of the nuances of
managing texture state,
setting data, and doing all this
other stuff is handled
behind the scenes
on your behalf.
That's great.
That means you can just make
your game and focus
on making your game.
It's definitely hand-free
usage.
It's behind the scenes.
And the user most importantly
can toggle this with a flag.
So if by some chance they've got
a beefier CPU than they do
a GPU, the user can then go in
toggle, turnoff hardware
accelerated canvas, and go
back to the CPU path.
We see this commonly in
notebooks or netbooks that may
have like six cores sitting
around but still have an
integrated graphics chip that
can't run Shader Model 1.1.
Cool.
So you've got all this stuff
working forward.
You've got this game
environment.
You've got it all set up.
Let's talk about the platform
environment.
So now that you're doing a web
game, let's talk about some
things you have to
be aware of.
Users will tab away
from your game.
If you're running in a browser,
users consistently
tab across to check their
email, during a loading
screen, or they get a chat, or
Groupon pops up and says, oh
my gosh, there's an amazing
cat for sale in Southern
California.
Like there's different reasons
for you to tab away.
You can detect this, and this
is an important thing.
You can actually listen for the
visibilitychange event in
JavaScript.
And that visibilitychange
event will give you a
notification when the user
has tabbed away.
And you need to respond
according to this so.
So for instance, you need to
pause the game first off.
If the player's in a multiplayer
match or doing
something important, you don't
want them tabbing away to
cause a problem in the game.
You want to make sure that you
pause properly and make sure
everything's kosher.
You can also reduce or
turn off volume.
This depends on your game.
Some people just choose to
reduce the volume so you kind
of notice that you're
still playing a game
and aware of it.
If you turn off the volume,
sometimes it's easy for the
user to forget they're
playing.
It's also worth noting that
setInterval during the time
that the user is a way will
actually slow down to about a
1,000 milliseconds, so about one
second pulses for anything
using setInterval.
If you're using
RequestAnimationFrame, it will
stop completely.
So make sure that you're aware
of these things in JavaScript.
If you're using either
setInterval or
RequestAnimationFrame and the
user tabs away, these things
will occur.
And you need to respond
accordingly to them.
Bugs in the wild.
So users will run your product,
and they will run
your product on their machine in
their environment on their
particular test harnesses with
their particular installation
configurations and extensions
and pop-ups and everything
else that's all there.
And they're going to hit
a bug sooner or later.
It's just the configuration
world.
Your job is to detect this on
their machine and get the
information back in an
appropriate way so that you
can update your product to
be a better product.
Again all going back to
optimizing for the end user
experience.
So you can detect this.
So if the user has an error
that's thrown, you can use
window.onerror.
Or if you're using any browser
that implements v8, which is
Chrome's JavaScript virtual
machine, you can actually use
Error.captureStackTrace and
this will give you a full
stack trace to where
the error is.
Once you detect this, you need
to respond accordingly.
You need to gather
information.
So it's not just enough
sometimes to get your stack.
You actually need to gather
other information like the
game specific or game
state, the operating
system, the player ID.
Maybe this one player keeps
getting crashes, and you need
to correlate that
with who it is.
In addition to that, there's two
really cool things here,
window.performance and
chrome.tabs.captureVisibleTab.
These are excellent useful
resources as well, because it
allows you give a
bigger picture.
For instance, what if the reason
that the game keeps
crashing on this user's machine
is because they have
some extension installed that
allows them to arbitrarily
break point JavaScript or make
everything in a floating point
integer or something.
Who knows?
Querying these things allow
you to get better
visibility in that.
Once you get the information--
so you detected it, you've
gathered your information,
and now you need to
get it back to you.
And there's two primary
ways to do this.
The first of course is you
just spin up a thread and
shoot off an email to yourself,
which is fine and dandy.
Of course, you have to worry
about what that means to send
an email from the user's
account and
all this other stuff.
You can also upload it.
And there's two nice little
software solutions called
jsErrLog and jdrop.
Click the links.
Check those out.
Basically those allow you to
sort of upload some sort of
JSONized string data to a server
database somewhere, and
then you can come back at your
convenience and scrub through
the number of crashes for that
day, rank them, implement them
into your bug system, and
respond accordingly.
Now here's an interesting
point.
And a lot of people don't--
they sort of understand
this, but it's a
nuance that they miss--
is that you make sure
that your error
reporting is stable.
The most annoying thing I've
ever had to debug is my
debugging code.
Like my I'm finding a crash
that's being caused by
something that I can't use
because my code that's trying
to detect the crash
is actually the
thing causing the crash.
Like it's a sort of Inception,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
all the way down.
So make sure your error
reporting is stable.
When you do detect a user, it's
sort of best practices to
tell the user that you've
detected this and display it
to the user in some very
friendly methodology.
Make sure that you communicate
that it's not their fault.
Nothing's more annoying than a
game that tells me that I'm
playing it wrong.
Your users don't like that.
Definitely avoid technical
language.
When Chrome crashes,
what do get?
You get a little funny
icon that kind of
brightens your day.
And it says hey, something's
crashed.
Sometimes it says ah, snap
or he's dead, Jim.
It makes humor.
It makes light of the fact that
your data is somehow no
longer there but don't worry.
Grass will still grow, babies
will still laugh, and we will
recover your data at a
point in the future.
Once you display it,
make sure that you
respect your user's privacy.
Ensure that the user knows what
you're gathering, what
you're returning as far as
your data's concern.
And allow the user to opt-out.
This is just sort of
a nice thing to do.
Allow the user to say
you what, I know
what the problem was.
I was trying to hack
you system.
Please don't use this
information.
Or hey, I know what
the problem is.
It's this other plug-in.
Don't send the information
around.
Allow them to opt-out.
Once you've got your JavaScript
data, it's
important to minify
and obfuscate it.
This is actually really
important.
So your JavaScript code will
actually take up a large chunk
of your memory footprint.
And you want to reduce sort of
duplicate characters and white
spaces and other things so that
it's transferred to the
user in the most efficient
methodology possible for
JavaScript.
The closure compile offers this
as well as obfuscation.
So this will actually allow your
code to be obfuscated to
a level that a standard human
being just taking a look at
the code won't be able to
actually detect what's going
on inside of it.
They'll need to spend some time
deobfuscating it to get there.
plovr, I think is the proper
way to do this is sort of a
front end to the closure
compiler.
Definitely take a
look at that.
And HTML5 boiler plate also
contains some really amazing
tools for minimization and
obfuscation that you should be
looking at if you're writing
content in JavaScript that is
performance and size heavy.
User metrics.
Now we're getting into
the cool stuff.
So you should know who your
players are and you should be
using Google Analytics
to do this.
Now Google Analytics as I've
said before is traditionally a
web service that allows you to
track who's visiting your
site, where they're coming from,
what pages get the most
traffic, et cetera, et
cetera, et cetera.
But you can also kickoff custom
events, and this is amazing.
This means that from JavaScript,
you can kick off
an event that's attached to
something going on your game.
So you can say every time a
user, any user finishes level
two I'm going to report that to
Google Analytics and keep
that data around.
Now I don't have a slide for it,
but the tools for Google
Analytics are actually
really amazing.
They're kind of from the future
in terms of ability to
analyze data and look at it
for specific spikes and
reasons that you need.
So if you save things like
finish level 2, finish the
game, how many users chatted,
how many users joined a group,
how many users kicked
a chicken.
This is important information.
If you put chickens and you
allow a user to kick a
chicken, you should probably
figure out how many users are
actually doing that thing so you
can figure out whether or
not you need to make it
a quest or an upgrade.
Like hey, you've kicked
a million chickens.
Halo 3 did a great
job of this.
And this is actually one of the
first documented sort of
in the wild publications.
What you're looking at
here is a heat map.
What happened was the designers
of Halo 3 during the
early testing days started
logging every
place that a user died.
So any time a player died, they
put that point in space.
And then they would generate
these heat maps of specific
multiplayer maps every day.
And what you see here is in the
red, that's where all the
deaths occur.
You can see in the blue,
not so many deaths.
Now you can take this
information and then
correlate, hey, see
these red areas?
That's where all
the action is.
Why is all the action there?
Is there some sort of power up,
or is it a choke point, or
is it a strategic interest You
can then take this information
and go back to redesign
how your game works
based upon this data.
And you can do this through
Google Analytics kicking off
these custom events.
So the high points.
What do you want to track?
So let's say cool.
You buy into it.
You're going to use it.
What are you going to track?
You should use Google Analytics
for the number of
daily, weekly, and monthly users
that are actually using
your product.
You should track the number of
players coming from what site.
You should know whether or not
you're getting more players
from Rock, Paper, Shotgun versus
Kotaku, and know how to
respond accordingly to that.
You should definitely know how
many players actually click
the buy button.
That's super important.
Because you should also know
how many players actually
complete the buy button.
This is an important metric.
This tells you how many people
are dropping off inside of the
monetization process.
How many do were willing to
buy the product versus how
many people actually do.
Now for some things, Google
Analytics doesn't work well.
And in these cases, you should
probably propagate data back
to your own server.
For some in-game events,
this is probably the
best way to do it.
Like number of crashes, bugs,
specific errors, or anything
that may need some specific
processing that Google
Analytics isn't best
suited for.
AB testing.
This is a great thing you
should all be doing.
Now web developers know this.
They know that there is a secret
sauce to a better game.
And it comes from the fact
that there's a direct
disconnect between game
developers and users.
This is just the
way of things.
As a game developer, I super
think that this amazing quest
where I take a chicken and wear
it as a hat for three
hours is the most amazing,
visceral experience that every
player will ever go
through ever.
In reality, only two people play
this game, me and my mom
because I told her to play
it and give me feedback.
Now why I'm getting feedback
from my mom on a quest, that's
a different talk.
We'll talk about that later.
But the important thing is that
in order to connect with
my user which is the person
playing the game, I need a
different way to get
that information.
AB testing is the process of
issuing a separate build to a
percentage of your users in such
a way that you can then
track the results to determine
what your proper outcome is.
So for instance, the most simple
version of this is
currently our buy button
when you want to
buy an item is red.
What if we change
it to be blue?
Does that have any effect on
the amount of people that
monetize our game?
Let's find out.
Let's make a build with a blue
button, issue it to 50% of the
people that log in today.
50% of people keep
the red button.
Did we see any change?
If not, if so what does
that mean to you?
This allows you to
make changes that
optimize your outcome.
Because it's not just as simple
as what kind of button
color it is.
But it's also based
upon region.
Like do people in Germany
buy the same way
as people in America?
Could I change my layout
to optimize
for that region better?
You can actually create multiple
versions of your game
and your front end effectively
based upon region.
Like maybe in Japan, your game
needs more happy happy fun
time music.
You don't know that until you
issue AB testing to get to
that information.
All right.
The thing you've all been
waiting for-- monetization.
Our deep dark scientists here at
Google have taken a look at
monetization and what's been
working for games.
And in an anonymous fashion,
we're going to sort of report
some of the things that you
should be looking at if you're
developing web games today.
So the first off is that
monetization is a dark art.
What works for one game does
not work for every game.
And you need to make sure you
understand that first off.
You can't just grab a game and
say I'm going to monetize like
they're monetizing.
It has a lot to do with how
integrated it is with your
game, with your product, and
with your environment.
So with that being said, you
need to make sure that you're
holding the user's hand.
For instance, we go through
this entire process of
teaching the user how to play
the game, and we never teach
them how to purchase an item.
We've actually seen that the
games that include purchase in
the tutorial monetize on average
about 30% better than
those who don't.
That's amazing.
Just showing the user how to--
give them some free credits.
Let them buy something during
the tutorial to show them the
store so that they're
not afraid of it.
Show them what the
benefits are.
Allow them to browse around.
We've got some other cool
statistics that show the user
who do buy during that process
are tons more sticky.
We'll share that information
at a different time.
Most importantly with this is
why they should purchase.
Getting them early in this
process and showing them how
they should purchase
allows them to also
see why it's available.
Most of the time users play a
game, they don't have any
bearing or understanding about
what's available and why they
care about it.
For instance, I never knew there
was a sword of Antioch
that was worth 50-50 power.
It allowed me to assault
chickens from here until the
Great Gates of Nagral.
But now that I do know, I
want to buy that sword.
Getting them in there
and showing them
that item is important.
This is a great graph.
This is an amazing graph.
And if you've been reading
anything on monetization in
games recently, you should
already know
the outcome of this.
What this shows is three
line points.
This is from a particular
product that launched a full
version that you could
buy up front.
So you pay $5.99 and you get the
full version, and a free
version at the same time.
So they said pay $5
or don't pay $5.
I don't really care.
It also provided in-app purchase
so that you can
actually purchase items
in the game.
So you're looking at this
time line here.
In the blue on the bottom,
you're actually looking at the
full purchase.
So this is just the amount of
money that came from buying
the game, just without
anything else.
Just buy the game up front.
You can see that in the blue.
The green is the amount of money
made from the people who
bought the full game--
so upfront price--
as well as in-app purchase.
So they bought the game, they
spent $5, and then they spend
an additional $10 or $11
buying upgraded items.
The pink or the orange depending
on what your monitor
color is and how this gets
compressed on YouTube is
actually the total input
from the free app
just for in-app purchase.
Which means these people didn't
buy up front version.
They just spent all of their
money in the game actually
buying items. It's through
the roof in a
couple different places.
But in general, it just
over-monetizes everything.
And the reason for this
can be twofold.
Number one, it could be that the
number of users who got in
the door to buy the item
were much larger.
So let's say that the free
version to in-app purchase had
3x to 4x the number of users.
Or the users just felt more
generous because they didn't
already pay $5 to get
the application.
But the point of this graph--
and we're seeing other results
show this--
is that making your game free to
play, some content free to
play with some form of in-app
purchase for content expansion
is definitely the way to go.
Now once you do this though,
you're going to ask yourself
what kind of virtual goods
should I be selling?
If we're going to embrace this
in-app purchase thing, what
should I be doing?
There's a great graph by
Flurry that's online.
Go grab it.
Take a look at it.
Which actually shows the
breakdown of durable goods and
who's buying what.
So first off, we notice that
personalization items through
in-app purchase are
only about 2%.
So only about 2% of transactions
in this graph are
for hey, I would like to buy
that shiny chicken hat that
clucks any time I get next
to someone else who
has a chicken hat.
Only about 2%.
About 30% are durable items.
These are effectively items
that you buy and then keep the
rest of your gaming existence.
So the sword of Antioch that I
then keep until I'm level 90.
Only about 30% buy that.
Where the big money is actually
in consumable goods.
And basically consumable
goods are goods that
have a limited lifespan.
So pay $0.99 to get a speed
boost for the next hour.
Or also included in this item
is virtual currency.
So pay $5 to get 200 coins.
And then the coins can then be
used to purchase other items
in the game.
Virtual currency is considered
a consumable good.
And as you can see, that whole
section of consumables--
so limited lifetime objects--
are actually dominating how
people are buying nowadays.
So let's talk about virtual
currency for a second.
So if you have virtual currency,
the numbers actually
show that you should have a
multiple currency system.
Not a multiple virtual currency,
but a multiple
currency system.
So you should be able to allow
your users to effectively buy
premium currency from in-app
purchases, and then also have
some sort of grind currency
from game play.
So I play this level, I
kick a chicken, the
chicken drops one bronze.
Cool.
I got a bronze.
But then I can go and
buy for $5 100 gold.
And really the metric here this
starts getting cool is
that you allow trading
between currencies.
So I can turn my 100 gold into
5,000 copper or vice-versa.
And this creates this really
interesting dynamic that the
user feels like they're smart
because they feel like they're
in control.
They can either spend $5 to get
the item or they can go
grind for five hours to get
the same item and the same
cost and then translate between
the two to buy more
items. This is really cool.
Empowering your user and letting
them know that they're
in control and they feel smart
is the best way to monetize
and keep players coming back.
It also enables instant
gratification.
So if I go to buy an item and
I don't have enough virtual
currency sitting around, you
should probably allow the user
to buy that item without
virtual currency.
Nothing's more annoying than
saying I want to buy this
sword, but before I can actually
pay you for it, I
have to go buy 100 coin
points and then go
back and buy the sword.
No.
What you should say is hey, you
don't have enough credits
available to you.
Would you like to buy this sword
for face value at $7.99.
And this is also a great point
that once you present this to
the user, you actually have
a chance to upsell.
You've now got their
attention.
Hey, you don't have enough
points to buy this.
You can either buy it for $7.99
or what you could do is
buy 1,000 credits and
we'll give you the
sword for 50% off.
That's an interesting
correlation.
You now have the user's
attention.
It's tied to an object they
want, and they see value in a
different proposition.
That's really cool and you
should take advantage of that.
You should also take advantage
of simplified purchase flow.
So when the user wants to buy
your item, you should make it
as easy as possible
for them to do so.
So leverage in-app
payment APIs.
Rather than directing the user
to some other site that they
then have to go through that
site and get through that
purchase flow in and then get an
item and then come back and
enter a key code, that
just doesn't work.
You should be using
in-app APIs.
And some of these things
have great features.
So for example, you get access
to millions of credit cards
for these APIs.
You have powerful fraud
engines that
exist on the back side.
Plug and play purchase
flow through
JavaScript and whatnot.
And you get to play
in a few clicks.
And Google Wallet provides
all of these things.
So with Google Wallet, you can
actually issue JavaScript
commands to a server, allow the
user to buy items. You get
access to anyone who's got
availability of a credit card
existing in Google Wallet.
We've already got fraud engines
set up, purchase flow,
and all this other stuff.
Use Google Wallet.
You should definitely leverage
this as opposed to forcing the
user to go through some
third party site.
So let's talk about the high
points here or the takeaways
or take outs.
So first off, bundle your assets
into segment archives.
Really important.
Set your proper caching times
for both data and query stuff
on Google App Engine.
Provide a single login for your
users so that they don't
have to create multiple sessions
or multiple users.
Localize your content
properly.
Super important there.
Be able to detect your GPU
blacklisted and performance
problems and alert
the user early.
Nothing's more annoying than a
user spending an hour trying
to get a game to run to finally
be told through
frustration that they can't
play the application.
Make sure that you detect and
fetch bugs in a wild.
You need to be able to know
what's going on in the
universe that you can fix
it and create a better
experience.
You should also make sure that
when the user tabs away that
you detect that and
respond properly.
You should track the data of
your users so you can optimize
your game for their
experience.
And you should choose a
monetization metric
that fits your game.
It's probably one of the most
important points there.
And if you do, once you have
chosen that monetization
method if you do you choose
a path that focuses on
consumable goods, make sure you
focus on consumable and
durable because that's where the
largest portion of the pie
is for in-app purchase.
And then finally, for in-app
purchase, definitely use the
Google Wallet API.
It's available.
It's usable.
It's quick to get started and
it's amazing what kind of
power it gives you.
So in general, it takes lots of
work to develop a game that
has nothing to do
with your game.
A lot of the things we talked
about had nothing to do with
path finding or play balancing
or how to properly get a sword
to whack a demon, like
nothing of that.
This is all back end stuff.
And because of that, you should
be leveraging services
that make it easy.
You want to be spending time
optimizing your game, not
spending time optimizing
these other services.
The fantastic thing is Google's
got a lot of services
that we have available for
you to get started.
Definitely use them.
Definitely take advantage of
them, and make sure you get
your game the best it can be.
So a big thanks to Pong Yang
and Fred Sauer, as well as
Chrome Developer Relations
for input on this talk.
Thank you very much.
Hit me up with any questions you
have. I'm available here.